[Music]  are you hungry for something good  [Music]  something juicy  how are you doing  [Music]  it's summer and sex cells baby  big things are coming for summertina  take off those bulky jeans to be more  aerodynamic oh you're doing it already  great big things like that eight racks  you get sometimes  bigger  stay low follow my lead  come come sleep  how  about just the gasp is great thank you  like this  i think we got it that last one was good  okay  not what i was expecting  i'm the marketing department i took  gene's burger suit let out the crotch a  little bit and bam a burger with a  bikini on it oh yeah  i get it no questions from this guy  [Music]